-Guys, as you know, every week,
we like to bring you
some uplifting, creative videos,
whether they come from
quarantine or just stuff
around the country.
It's time for "What Are You
Doing Wednesday."
-♪ What do you do
when it's Wednesday? ♪
♪ What do you do when
it's Wednesday? ♪
-First up, this toddler
really wanted to
close his refrigerator door.
-[ Laughing ] Stop. No. No.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-Hold up.
Can I get out the fridge?
-[ Crying ]
-My bad. No problem.
-Yeah.
That's settled. There you go.
Next, this husband
couldn't find his wife,
so he went out
and checked in the driveway.
Look at this.
-And I want y'all to see
what I just saw.
I'm in here cooking dinner,
watching the kids,
cleaning up dishes.
And I came out here
to throw some trash away,
and what I found
was Allison out here
eating a Push Pop while I'm in
there making dinner for her.
And now she's trying to hide
from it, but I caught her.
-Who are you talking to?
-I caught her.
She's out here. Look at her.
I said, "Hey, go get us
some drinks
while I'm out here cleaning up
the dishes and making dinner
and watching the kids.
Just run to
the store real quick."
And I come out here and
catch her eating a Push Pop.
-Busted. And, finally,
this person managed to catch
the beginning of
a beautiful friendship.
[ Luciano Michelini's
"Frolic" playing ]
-There you go, everybody.
That is "What Are
You Doing Wednesday."